it doesn't matter what's happened I
don't care what's happened I don't care
what you honor this person is on this is
what I like you know that why my my life
is telling me for me if I was going to
be successful I had to be successful
with myself I couldn't be successful
doing what other people were doing I had
to do what I believed in I like to
advance every year to advance myself you
know spiritually mentally everything I
like to advance myself I have more fair
going back and losing money he is an
American rapper and businessman he's one
of the best-selling musicians of all
time having sold over 100 million album
he has an estimated net worth of 610
million dollars
he's jay-z and here's my take on his top
ten rules of success volume 2 rule
number one is my personal favorite and
I'd love to know which one you guys like
the best and as always you're watching
if you hear something that really
resonates with you please leave in the
comments below put quotes around it to
other people can be inspired as well and
when you write it down it's much more
likely to stick with you as well enjoy
I love what I do
and even you love what you do you want
to be the best at it you know you know
you know make music to be second best
you make music to be the best so you
whatever you do whatever you do not be
music you're not sitting here trying to
UM you know be just you know be second
to Piers Morgan on one of those because
a load
saint-lo don't want to be that you don't
want to be second in saying lo you're
looking at Zane Lowe like are you
kidding me in a good way I mean only you
know in a good way like are you kidding
me like I do this like I've been doing
this so long so so sometimes you have to
throw your stats out there to remind
people your last name better than my
first you know it's a true statement to
me like there's a lot of people latch
things it I mean it's reason without
those it's hard to be you know I'm sad
and uh you know you just have to put
your stats out there to remind people
like yo you know I'm the real deal the
worst thing to be is successful with
someone else yeah that's a very
difficult thing to upkeep and it's very
tiring you know I feel sorry for someone
who has to walk out the house every day
as someone else to make this art and to
make something that people connect to
and whatever you've made is not you and
you don't you're not happy about it but
it's successful
just to maintain that number of
successes it has to be very draining and
you know very sad existence because at
some point you have to go home when you
go home you know it all the lights off
and all everything's up and you have to
look in the mirror you have to look at
yourself and say man I like Who I am all
not very happy with who I am by my third
album I had the combination of failing
with those pop records and the true and
real music that I wanted to make and I
blended those two together and I made a
song called hard-knock life and that
album was when I knew um that I can do
it
no one cares whether you live or die and
that's where that mentality grows that
imma get it on my die tryin
if I don't try what am i doing what kind
of life but my favorite like these
things is wicked in these mean streets
none of my friends speak we all trying
to win we all trying to win and a lot of
times we bumping hands because we all
trying to get out that's like the crabs
and the barrel mentality you know that
we have because everyone's trying to
survive and they trying to survive at
any court you have to look at that you
got to look at the environments and
places we live it and how things are set
up and how things are structured and how
we're always the last on the totem pole
even for my school into our roads so you
know everything that would get all
obstacles that's placed in front us even
I live in condition and broke is a great
motivator have 26 floors and there's a
ton of them right these low-income
houses and everything is messed up it so
living that's like living dummy if this
is like that's what I have to live for
and I'm going to take a chance to get
more it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
what happens to me
any people feel like people consume
music too fast because you create these
amazing moments within the moment it's
sleeting soon as you put the eye of
minds like people haunted for a few days
then okay Jay Cole came out while he
comes out the next week while lays out
now holds out you know me yeah yeah it's
just yeah again again the time that we
end right we we have to figure out I
mean it's up to an individual figure out
how to slow it down because you know
it's just going fast and fat
so everything is moving even quicker you
know information is going quicker you
know it's again like you said you know
these these great things are fleeting
they're going faster and faster and it's
up to the individual to slow it down and
be like okay I'm living with this album
this is what I'm this I choose the rock
so this is going to be the soundtrack to
my life for these next couple months or
so I'm saying yes that's an individual
thing I'm not going to anybody speed up
my process I don't care what's happening
out there that's just that's the great
thing about you know having ultimate
confidence in yourself is it doesn't
matter what's happening I don't care
what's happening on care which you honor
this person is on this is what I like
you know that a lot of my my life is
telling me for me I learn more from
failures and success and it can be
paralyzing this um failure and the fear
of it my first time I made was album
core reasonable doubt which in the small
circles was considered the album like in
classic album might be album for that
generation in the voice of you know
people that were going through similar
situations but it didn't sell massive
numbers worldwide right it was still
very niche in my second album because of
you know reasonable doubt and its lack
of commercial success you know I try to
make these records that were bigger and
will be more popular which was a failure
going for that success really messed up
that project and you know set a bad tone
it was a huge learning lesson for me
that if I was going to be successful I
had to be successful with myself I
couldn't be successful doing what other
people were doing I had to do what I
believed in and what felt real to me and
felt true to me I started even in my
beginning you know I just lived such a
rich life you know a full life you know
that you know my first album I came out
I was 26 and I had seen so many things
in the streets on my head my attitudes
like man oh you know I've seen so much
and you know I don't have anything to
prove I Know Who I am I'm a very
self-aware person you know so when
you're self-aware even when you're
dealing with someone's ego you can you
know
when allow it to you you allow their ego
to live in its own space you know it's
the product only the problem is if you
when you and when you engage that energy
that's when it's a problem if you engage
the ego with your ego then it's like
okay now something has to happen they
can keep escalating to a level that can
uh we we uh it reversible you know but
if you don't engage the ego if you know
how to manipulate or play around with
the ego or love certain you give light
back to darkness right it's very
difficult
I've more fear of going back going back
to you know I like to advance every year
to advance myself when you know
spiritually mentally everything I like
to advance myself I'm more fair going
back and losing money you know like I
said when I was I'm lost money I've been
broke up in shops they've been blown
bread mm-hmm celebrity yeah Oh what it
but as well you know money is just a
byproduct and that sound it sounds
really cliche but it's true of going to
you know a great job where as a start
approaching you know got on this
audience starts approaching September I
thought it was only right to bring it
full circle being that the first one
came out on the eleventh year um this
being the end of the trilogy to put it
out on eleventh in this way we could
recognize what happened that day because
the first time of course it wasn't
claimed right you know but the thing
about blueprint one is people hold that
album like sacred to their heart that's
a lot of people's favorite album as I go
a classic my favorite jail it's my
favorite your favorite jayob lever and
I'm like the underground you know
backpack nerd do nice think a reasonable
doubt but then blueprint actually
probably eclipse that is my favorite jam
yeah so that when you put out blueprint
three people obviously going to compare
it to the first one why didn't you just
put out another album why didn't have to
be blueprint three I'm used to that type
of pressure I put out blueprint I'll put
our reasonable doubt you know that was
supposed to be the classic you know yeah
but you have a
reason about reasonable doubt - hold on
for second all that sighs oh well I'll
get up as a man God cut you up and
everything that publicity Volume one
right the volume two in volume three
that was another trilogy so I wanted the
blueprint series debut trilogy because
of what it represented the first
blueprint was you know those soul
samples that I grew up on it was my
blueprint then we loop ring tools me
searching for all the different type of
music you know that I like but I have a
reason to do the third one boom so I
didn't do it for a while and I held it
off I did the blackout method I didn't
all those other albums come but you know
it just was fitting right now where I am
in my career for you know me to set the
blueprint for my next journey that music
is really up I'm like microcosm of life
you know my music is based on life and
the things I've experienced like I made
a song called give it to me which was
inspired and totally by a party that I
went to by mary j blige it's when she
hears that song she knows exactly
because she was this you know exactly
what I'm talking about
so it's pretty much inspired by life so
anything is inspiration a lot of times
you're flying at 50,000 feet you need
someone to always keep you grounded
I have great friends around me who you
know I don't shun the advice you know I
encourage the advice which i think is
very important you can live in your own
alternative universe with how people
treat a celebrity these days but you
know long as you keep good friends
around you and also not putting yourself
in a box and becoming a prisoner your
fame a lot of people wants to become
famous they stop doing things they did
they don't go to the store or you become
a prisoner of your fame and I I've
always been up we're in our cognitive
that not to let that it allow that to
happen
little boy - Brooklyn made it from the
start
girl out south made it - shots okay
I'm freestyling this okay you're just
making it up right there we go
Oh am i funny did made it out stuff
girlf Moscow made it out shot
Mumma oh man up shot well Moslems that
made it out Shah only goes to show that
the limit is the sky if they gave you
lemons and you make lemon pie
[Applause]
me I'm from Brooklyn
hi so I made it off the sky you come out
the south you made it from neighbors
shining into the shy shy bound got it
only goes to show only goes to show at
the limit is the sky only goes to show
that the limit is the sky life gives you
lemons you make lemonade to beat over
I'm from Brooklyn
stop okay well you're going to start it
right okay little boy Brooklyn baby from
the stock girl Moscow made it to the shy
gonna shop hate it to the shy
yeah hate it for the shot you own me the
hand okay keep it small you know
quack-quack okay yeah boy from out
Brooklyn reading on the star girl from
down south
Mason shot only go to show that the
limit is the sky like geeky limits then
you make lemon hi
[Applause]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Eduardo Guzman
asked me to also if you want to nominate
someone for the next top ten video
please check the description for a link
to a video where you can vote for people
and put in your suggestions as well I'd
love to know what did you take from this
video what was the most important lesson
that you learned that blew your mind
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or your business somehow
please leave it down the comments below
I'm super curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to John
Jenkins John thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book through one
word and doing the review on your
YouTube channel I really appreciate the
support man and I'm glad you enjoyed the
read
I just want to too much new Pokemon so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
someone has to experiment and go do it
first and then you know they'll be the
artist you know auditors sit back and
watch it and be like okay I like this I
don't like that you know I like this
part and they're perfect the methods and
then you know and it all pushes your
armor forward any time that you try to
do something different and you should
always try to you know push push forward
and whatever you're doing is going to be
problems because it has never been done
before so you can't again you can't
anticipate all the things that's going
to happen you know I don't write
anything when I'm recording I don't
write lyrics I just listen to the music
and I formulate the song like just off
the top of my head I just go over the
lyrics again and again until I have the
song and I just going in I record it so
it definitely god-given talent and it
was Drive also it was Drive I mean it
was tough I mean we toured the whole
eastern seaboard that's where I record
we did play we we can we listen mashing
you yet so we would talk all the way up
to North Carolina or just like hit that
area
not even Atlanta which is all over to
North Carolina we would talk just jump
in the van and just drive ourselves and
just do endless endless shows I mean
with 20 people in the building sometimes
generally yeah always believing we get
better and better than ever I just shot
it I shot a commercial on
when this album that came out and it was
like keep going back from times to all
my album covers and uh you know I had to
recreate him and it was and I realized
how easy was recreate I had the same
haircut the same thing in every single
shot so I don't know if I've been grated
reinventing myself but um as far as the
company we have the opportunity to
reinvent ourselves for out of necessity
if everything that's going on you have
to reinvent yourself the playing field
has changed it's difficult in the music
business because the internet and
everything that's going on but if you're
fearless
it's a beautiful time for entrepreneurs
the most fun I had in music business was
us having this little rinky-dink record
company and you know growing up in radio
stations and in other places as if we
were Universal you know speaking as if
we you know we sold a hundred million
records only in fact we sold nothing so
it feels like that time again for me
because the models have to be redefined
and and that's exciting to me I don't
know if you ever done right it's almost
like climbing a mountain and you see
another mountain and you go to the next
one and the next one my goal is to have
one gold album and know that it became
more from there you know and all the way
up until the black album didn't became I
want I want I want to show that you know
artists can ascend to the executive
ranks you know it just kept redefining
themself you know and which is why to
hold the presidency of Def Jam it just
keeps reinventing itself or redefining
myself every single day